I remember I always liked in the Bible
where you know Moses was offered you
know what would you like all the gold
and and he said I want wisdom in a dream
and that that made when I was a very
young girl reading the scriptures I
thought that was a good choice
and I thought well what is wisdom it's
not just the books wisdom for me isn't
just all the wisdom that man creates in
all the books I created a belief system
somehow in that there is a higher order
and I always call it you know and horses
it was the sea of possibilities it's the
you know partially the collective pool
of knowledge but also whatever whatever
is out there you know whatever the the
the star is give us the planets the gods
anybody and that you know that is a
reason to seek you know for you know
when you think of Alan or anyone
spirituality wasn't just you know some
of it is love based of course loving
better the fellow man which is it you
know earthly spirituality but the the
desire for a higher consciousness
whether through drugs meditation you
know religion however you get there so
important to the the beats and of course
Beethoven anyone it's not like the beats
invented it but since I've I knew them
they were all looking for more knowledge
not just sensation not like you know
more sexual energy some of its sex based
but was more knowledge based and I was
very very privileged to be around these
men my say men because they were all men
it's not a you know it whatever but I
was a girl is it but whether it was
Gregory Corso or any of them all of them
seeking you know Gregory the highest
aspect of poetry William opening
consciousnesses is you know levels of
consciousness
know through drugs through the third
mind and all of these people were
looking for more not more money not more
power not more gold but a higher
consciousness you know and that to me is
completely linked it's somewhat work
based because I'm a work centric person
so anything that filters into me I want
to you know transform into a poem or
something but you know it's they that's
they they sought that you know and the
Beatles sought it you know all kinds of
people seek it you know you're seeking
it's not just you know seeking something
greater that they knew so you can feel
sheltered and comforted it's just more
some more awareness some you know as I
written you know some new letter of the
ancient alphabet you know an alphabet
that we haven't discovered yet that has
even more information it's all out there
and to me that is that is very connected
with what people call spirituality I
have been talking this afternoon under
the title of this symposium is in
education counterculture what is for the
three of you the essence of Education
what does it when they bring you an ID
in it to be educated what does it mean
to be educated your professor so how can
you know exactly curiosity and wonder
you know the sense of of finding some
aspect of human endeavor and following
it and you know for me you know it can
be anywhere I in my sense of
spirituality it's very much created
within an inner creativity and it's not
just like working in the arts doing a
painting or writing or playing music you
know I I can find spirituality in a
great meal you know the stump pot and we
had yesterday
what a great dish oh my god but the fact
is that yeah you know I believe we're
all part of this human organism some
people are builders you know some people
are auto mechanics you mentioned that in
the art of motorcycle maintenance I mean
when I was fascinated by motorcycles
when I was in my mid-40s and had nothing
to do with having a midlife crisis even
though I had six motorcycles by the end
of that decade you know there's
something beautiful about an engine
that's perfectly in tune and if you can
get that engine in tune that means
you're in tune with yourself I would
know when I would go around a curve and
I was really focused and going around at
80 miles an hour and knowing I have to
be the machine and be aware of it and
not look at you know the fact that you I
mean all of these things these things
matter but in terms of you know the
human mind is so incredible you know you
look at what they've done with this this
computer and and the amount of ways in
which it can expand our human endeavor
and the dangers with that as well you
know I find my sense of curiosity you
know through the world of music to find
that great b-side of a 45 that nobody's
found and be illuminated you know by
that and and to know that some crazy
person out somewhere made that you know
that that to me is is education I mean I
you know you can learn certain aspects
of what you need to know in life by a
regular schooling but in the end you got
a school yourself what I've learned is
is you know these kind of outlier
subcultures which I've spent my life in
whether it's you know you know comic art
or everything there are expressions of
the human spirit and you can find your
yourself within them
find your reflection of you know
whatever outer universe there is
reflecting down within us well you
started talking about stamina right and
the constriction of what an education
ought to be and I I do think that's a
problem a real problem there's a great
sense that education is supposed to be
vocational and and I'm not opposed to
vocation but vocation in the in the
spiritual sense means is calling and
that's not what it's what it's what it's
geared towards not geared toward a
calling or towards wisdom and evident
they've invented all these weird new
majors and Caroline's talking about this
I mean a communications major what does
it mean to major in communications I
have no idea but but it's a major it's a
major and and what it means is they're
going to slot you into some stupid job
someplace that's no that's effects for
that and it's not about communicating
that's the last thing it's about so I do
think there's a cry there's a problem I
won't say crisis but there's a problem
in American higher education in terms of
Education where it's getting very
divided I mean I see it as what for a
very small elite that used to be the
only people who had access to education
they are now going to remain educated
and they're gonna have access to all the
things that we're talking about here and
then the masses get the the slope the
masses get the you know the vote get
communications and and and I think
that's a real problem there's a lot of
ways to be educated I want to say that
you have to you know only rigueur to be
educated obviously that's not the case
although a little Goethe goes a long way
but but I do think that there's a way in
which we've where we're
instrumentalizing education too much and
and elite heisting it you know making it
only available to the elite again
you